les événements qui ont eu lieu ce matin
dans un lycée à haras nous ont tous
saisi des froids un professeur a été tué
plusieurs personnes sont blessées
j'exprime une nouvelle fois et en votre
nom à tous l'émotion de la
représentation nationale face à
l'horreur de ces actes ainsi que
d'emposser notre solidarité envers les
victimes et envers leurs familles cette
solidarité s'exprime également à l'égard
de la communauté éducative à laquelle
nous devons temps et qui a été déjà si
durement
éprouvé je vous invite mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre à
observer une minute de
silence
je vais à présent donner la parole à un
représentant de chaque groupe politique
ainsi que ministre puis je suspendrai
brièvement la séance pour que nous
puissions reprendre nos travaux
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Maillard pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
le groupe Renaissance s'associe à
l'hommage rendu à l'enseignant tué ce
matin nos pensées vont au blessés aux
proches des victimes ainsi qu'à toute la
communauté éducative aux élèves et à
leurs
famill 3 ans après aprs le lâche
assassinat de Samuel pti à nouveau à
nouveau un professeur a été tué au nom
du terrorisme islamiste si la même
horreur nous saisit 3 ans après c'est
qu'encore une fois prendre une école
pour cible ôter la vie d'un enseignant à
un but clair s'attaquer à nos principes
et à nos
valeurs celles qui sont transmises par
la devise au fronton de nos écoles
liberté égalité Frat frernité l'école de
la République doit être un lieu sacré
pour tous les citoyens toute attaque
contre elle c'est une attaque portée à
la nation dans son
ensemble le message que notre hémicycle
doit adresser à ceux qui répandent la
mort et la terreur estclair nous ne
céderons jamais jamais face à
l'obscurantisme
la parole est à Madame chikerou pour le
groupe la France
insoumise madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues le silence
qui nous a saisi ce matin à l'annonce de
l'ignoble et lâche assassinat d'un
professeur à haras la tristesse qui
s'est abatue sur nous tous la compassion
vis-à-vis des victimes de leur proches
et de la communauté éducative nous
unissent en cet instant nous savons ce
que cherchent les terroristes chaque
fois qu'il frappe SEM met la discorde et
la guerre nous devons résister comme
nous avons toujours résisté nous devons
refuser à l'ennemi commun celui qui sème
la terreur et la mort celui qui amène
les larmes et la douleur à celui-là nous
devons refuser la moindre victoire
jamais nous ne céderons à la haine
jamais jamais nous ne céderons à la peur
nos morts sont nos héros mais aussi nos
maîtres race aujourd'hui comme il y a 3
ans à Conflant saint-onorine comme il y
a 5 ans à treèbe nos morts nous obligent
leur mémoire leur histoire leurs valeurs
humanistes nous obligent à ceux qui
enseignent qui éduque qui transmettent
nous voulons dire notre amour fraternel
je reprends le mot d'Auguste conte toute
éducation humaine doit préparer chacun à
vivre pour autrui afin de revivre dans
autrui
professeur vous revivez déjà en
nous au nom du groupe insoumis je dis
notre détermination sans faille à nous
dresser face au terrorisme au
gouvernement et au services de l'État
vous pouvez compter sur nous les
insoumis sur tous nos élus pour faire
face
ensemble
merci la parole est à Madame Diaz pour
le groupe rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente les
députés du groupe rassemblement national
s'associent à l'émotion nationale
légitime nous adressons nos nos
condoléances à la famille de la victime
à ses amis à ses proches et nous avons
bien sûr une pensée émue de soutien à la
communauté enseignante qui a
malheureusement déjà fait les frais de
l'islamisme
radical quand Samuel Patti a été
assassiné il a été dit plus jamais ça
donc oui nous avons
essué nos larmes nous avons procédé à du
recueillement à des minutes de silence à
des fleurs des dépôts de fleurs à des
dépôts de nounours mais finalement rien
n'a été fait alors moi je voudrais
lancer un appel
solonnel il faut une réponse rapide
urgente parce que plus on attend plus
les Français devront pleurer leur mort
il y a bien entendu un lien évident
entre le meurtre que nous pleurons
aujourd'hui l'immigration massive dans
notre pays et l'absence de lutte
efficace contre l'islamisme radical donc
j'espère que tous vous prendrez vos
responsabilités pour protéger les
Français la parole est à Monsieur pour
le groupe les
[Musique]
républicainsadame présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues nous venons de
vivre aujourd'hui un acte effroyable au
sein du lycée Gambetta Carna d'as avec
la mort d'un enseignant et de deux
personnes blessées mes premières pensées
vont à la famille et aux victimes
auxquelles je souhaite exprimer au nom
de tous les députés du groupe les
républicains notre profond soutien la
République a été frappée en plein cœur 3
ans après le terrible décès de Samuel
paatti nous devons être d'une fermeté
intransigente vis ave de ces crimes
abominables nous tenons dans cet
hémicycle à saluer le courage
exceptionnel de ceux qui au péril de
leur vie ont tenté de maîtriser
l'assaillant dans la cour de
l'établissement avec une simple chaise
en guise de bouclier ce geste héroïque
et cette bravoure remarquable ont
certainement évité une tragédie encore
plus grande nous tenons également à
saluer les forces de l'ordre mobilisé
sur place et attendons les conclusions
du parquet antiterroriste afin de
comprendre les circonstances de ce drama
merci la parole est à Monsieur balanan
pour le compte démocrate merci madame la
Présidente député du groupe démocrate
nous avons une pensée lourde et remplie
d'émotions pour les victimes les proches
des victimes les témoins de cet acte de
barbarerie une pensée aussi pour les
héros qui se sont interposés et sans
doute ont sauvé des vies ce
matin nous pensons à nos enseignants des
femmes et des hommes qui ont choisi
cette vocation pour cultiver le terreau
de nos valeurs de notre République de
notre démocratie et de aussi surtout
notre
humanité l'école doit être le sanctuaire
de la tolérance de l'écoute de l'autre
de la connaissance et surtout de
l'apprentissage de la différence nous ne
devons pas céder à rien et en ce moment
dramatique nous devons dire et affirmer
notre détermination à repousser les
ennemis de l'esprit
français des ennemis de notre de nos
valeurs et les ennemis de la
[Musique]
République la parole est à monsieur le
Président Valo pour le groupe
socialiste madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
l'horreur a frappé ce matin AR ras comme
il y a 8 ans un autre vendredi dans les
rues de Paris et de Saint-Denis comme il
y a près de 3 ans jour pour jour avec la
décapitation de Samuel pti le terrorisme
a montré son immonde visage l'abjection
la plus brute et la plus inhumaine les
mots manquent pour dire tout à la fois
notre effroid notre peine et notre
compassion pour les victimes notre
colère aussi nous pensons à cet instant
à ce professeur assassiné aux blessés
aux élèves et à leurs enseignants et à
travers eux à l'ensemble de la
communauté
éducative nous pensons à leur famille et
à leurs proches aux policiers qui ont
interpellé l'assaillant et au personnel
de secours à leur
côté une fois encore ce matin c'est à un
professeur un professeur de lettre que
le terrorisme s'en est pris à la
République dans ce qu' a de plus incarné
et de plus vivante à la raison dans ce
qu'elle a de plus pur à la liberté dans
ce qu'elle a de plus
exigeante le terrorisme s'est attaqué à
l'école où tout commence où se met le
savoir où se construit l'esprit critique
où grandissent les
citoyens ce professeur est aujourd'hui
une victime et le deuil est national
mais il est en un sens déjà un héros par
le courage dont il a dont il a fait
preuve la raison contre le fanatisme la
liberté contre l'obscurantisme
l'humanité contre la haine la
culture notre devoir notre seul devoir
de républicain à cette heure et de
refuser au terrorisme quelque victoire
que ce soit et d'abord celle de notre
division et de notre faiblesse il veut
nous diviser nous serons Unis il veut
nous affaiblir nous serons forts il nous
veut à genou nous nous tiendrons debout
nous ne céderons rien face au terrorisme
et nous le combattrons sans relâche la
lutte ne nous divisera pas elle nous
rassemblera mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre je vous dire au nom
du groupe socialiste et apparenté que
nous sommes disponibles pour faire face
pour faire bloc et défendre la paix
civile et vous nous trouverez à vos
côtés au côté des Françaises et des
Français comme garant de l'unité de la
nation
merci la parole est à Madame Carel pour
le groupe
horizon madame la Présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues attaquer le
sanctuaire que devrait être notre école
c'est frappé au plein cœur de la
République quasiment 3 ans jour pour
jour après l'assassinat de Samuel paatti
professeur ciblé pour ce qu'il incarnait
un terroriste s'en prend une nouvelle
fois au corps enseignant ses passeurs de
savoir ses remparts contre
l'obscurantisme je tiens tout d'abord
ici à adresser toutes mes pensées aux
victimes aux blessés à leurs famille et
à leurs proches ainsi qu'à l'ensemble de
la communauté éduca
ils vivent en ce jour l'indiscible en
tant qu'enseignante je porte
naturellement ce deuil comme le portent
tous les Français nous enseignants
sommes des sentinelles de la République
et de la démocratie c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes visés au travers
des professeurs de France ce
sont ce sont tous les professeurs du
monde qui se battent dans la
transmission de la philosophie des
Lumières mes chers
collègues certains peuvent être tentés
de céder aux sirènes de la confusion et
de
l'immédiateté je vous en joins au
contraire et résister et faire bloc il
est de notre devoir de nous de ne pas
nous fracturer nous représentants de la
nation devons trouver les mots justes
pour apaiser les souffrances cela nous
impose de respecter le temps du deuil et
celui nécessaire à la justice afin
qu'elle fasse son œuvre restons digne
c'est le plus bel hommage que nous
puissions rendre à cette profession une
nouvelle fois meurtrie les auteurs de
ces actes inqualifiables cherchent à
nous diviser restons unis et portons
haut nos valeurs républicaines de
fraternité et de laïcité pour autant il
ne peut y avoir de répis pour les
ennemis de notre démocratie et de notre
civilisation nous devons rester
inflexibles face au terrorisme islamiste
les terroristes combattent la liberté
par la peur nous convaincrons la peur
par la
liberté merci Madame
Carel
merci la parole est à madame la
Présidente Chatelin pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente je
veux commencer par saluer la mémoire de
Dominique Bernard qui a perdu la vie en
protégeant ses élèves de nouveau
l'horreur les frroids la peur la mort a
frappé la communauté éducative 3 ans
presque jour pour jour après
l'assassinat de Samuel paatti dont nous
honorerons la mémoire ce
lundi alors que le traumatisme est
toujours là que la PL n'est pas refermé
c'est à toute la communauté éducative
que le groupe écologiste veut dire sa
solidarité et veut dire son
soutien nous voulons également dire dire
à tous les parents qui sont sous le choc
et qui peut-être sont inquiets pour la
sécurité de leurs enfants que nous
partageons leurs
angoisses nous voulons dire à tous ces
élèves qui ont dû se cacher sous des
tables que N ils n sommes pas seuls et
que la République sera là avec eux
l'assaillant a transformé un lieu
d'émancipation en un lieu de mort c'est
impardonnable ces attaques ont un
objectif c'est nous terroriser c'est
nous chasser des lieux où nous faisons
société c'est nous chasser des lieux où
nous faisons collectif des enceintes où
nous apprenons le vivre ensemble et où
nous aimons vivre ensemble notre réponse
notre choix est de ne jamais déserter
ces lieux de ne jamais céder à la haine
nous devons plus que jamais soutenir
notre école notre école publique et
l'ensemble de nos enseignants qui la
font vivre tout tous les jours enfin à
ceux qui veulent ébranler la République
nous voulons leur dire la France ne
vacira pas ne vacira jamais chaque jour
nous devrons uvrer ensemble à faire
vivre notre État de droit à faire vivre
nos libertés à vivire l'égalité et à
faire vivre la
fraternité je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Tellier pour le groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues le groupe GDR
qui rassemble les députés communistes et
les progressistes ultramarins s'associe
à l'hommage de la représentation
nationale face à l'attaque terroriste
odieuse dont ont été victime le
personnel de l'éducation nationale du
lycée Gambetta aras dans ce département
du ptecalais que j'aime tant nos pensées
vont d'abord aux victimes aux
professeurs décédés au blessés et je
veux assurer leur proches de toute notre
compassion 3 ans presque jour pour jour
après le meurtre atroce de Samuel paatti
nos enseignants notre école et à travers
eux toute la République doivent de
nouveau faire face au terrorisme et à
l'obscurantisme ns enseignants incarent
les fondements de notre République ils
sont les gardiens du savoir et des
idéaux républicains chaque fois qu'ils
sont pris pour cible nous devons nous
être
intrangigant la période sombre que nous
traversons nous oblige à la dignité pour
cela notre nation doit rester unie unie
au service de la paix et non de la haine
ou de la vengeance aveugle uni sans
instrumentalisation politique mais avec
lucidité le pire serait de tomber dans
le piège de la division nous nous devons
y faire face en ne sacrifiant jamais
notre humanité rien vraiment rien ne
détournera les députés de notre groupe
de leur combat pour un monde plus juste
plus égalitaire un monde de
paix
merci la parole est à Monsieur serva
pour le groupe liberté indépendant outre
ma et
territoire madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues je tiens à
associer les députés du groupe lot à
l'hommage à l'enseignant Dominique
Bernard lâchement assassiné ce matin
ainsi qu'aux autres victimes blessés
nous sommes tous une nouvelle fois
saisis au cœur hommage au personnel
enseignant du lycée Gambetta d'aras
hommage aux élèves et à toute la
communauté
éducative le temps est au recueillement
ces événements terroristes nous
rappellent à tous le précédent attentat
dont a été victime Samuel
pati nous disions à l'époque plus jamais
ça et nous devons mesurer les mois de
cet assassinat pour nos compatriotes
viendra ensuite le temps des
questionnements l'enquête devra démêler
les responsabilités des éventuelles
complicités les faits ne sont pas
clairement établis nous devons parler
nous parlementair avec
responsabilité ce qui est attaqué c'est
notre République ce qui est visé c'est
notre cohésion sociale nous résisterons
nous
vaincrons vous
remerci
monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les députés au moment où la
Nation toute entière est saisie une
nouvelle fois par l'effroid et par
l'émotion le gouvernement s'associe à
l'hommage rendu par l'Assemblée
nationale aux victimes le gouvernement
s'associe également à la douleur et au
deuil des familles des proches et de la
communauté
éducative le gouvernement salue la
bravoure exceptionnelle de celles et
ceux qui semblent s'être interposé
contribuant ainsi sans doute à épargner
des vies s'ans prendre à un professeur
c'est s'en prendre à la République et à
ses fondements la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité aussi face à l'horreur et à
la
lâcheté à la violence et au fanatisme
qui frappe une nouvelle fois notre école
sanctuaire de l'émancipation et du vivre
ensemble la République ne pliera jamais
ne transigera jamais ne cèdera
jamais dans cette douloureuse épreuve
infligée à la nation sachons mesdames et
messieurs les députés rester unis en
solidarité en fraternité avec les
victimes et avec la communauté
enseignante
merci Monsieur le
Ministre la séance est donc suspendu
pour quelques minutes